With the Microsoft Translator extension, you can now translate webpages from
over 50 different languages to your language of choice with the simple click of a button
making web content from around the world even more accessible to you on Microsoft Edge!
First, go to a website written in a Microsoft Translator supported language.
For this example we will use MSN Spanish.
As the page loads, you will see the Translator icon show up in the address bar.
Now, click on translate.
The webpage will be translated to your language.
You can also select some text, right click
and select translate in the context menu to get a translation for the selected text.
If you need to change any additional language settings,
you can simply go into "Options" and change your preferences.
Thanks for watching!